Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 298. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich sitze immer hier und dann sitzen Leute bei mir und wir greifen uns so ein Thema raus, was gerade so im Schwang ist. Also alle reden darüber, aber was ist es eigentlich? Oder von dem wir denken, darüber müsste man eigentlich mal reden. Und dann bieten wir so eine Art Einstiegsanfangserklärung hinter die Kulissen gucken. Immer dabei ist Konstanze Kohl, Zahlung und Tag.
Ja, hallo Markus.
Eine Sprecherin, die auch zur Presse spricht, des Chaos Computer Clubs, Autorin bei Netzpolitik Org, wo auch eine zweite Person herkommt, die heute hier ist, nämlich Ingo Dachwitz, hallo, guten Tag. Hallo. Du bist auch bei Netzpolitik Org und du hast zufälligerweise, ich sag das Thema, normalerweise sag ich mal erst das Thema und dann, aber hier passt es, weil du hast ein Buch rausgebracht, das ganz zufälligerweise denselben Titel trägt wie diese Folge, Digitaler Kolonialismus. Was das ist, besprechen wir gleich.
Naja, wir müssen ehrlich sein, jetzt wo wir aufnehmen, wir wollten ja mal sagen, wann wir aufnehmen, ist das Buch noch gar nicht erschienen, es kommt nämlich Donnerstag. Wir können uns alle noch drauf freuen, aber wenn der Podcast kommt.
Ich bin so ein bisschen skeptisch bei diesem engen Anwendung des Kolonialismusbegriffs auf das, was sozusagen Tech-Konzernen mit uns auch im globalen Norden machen, weil es eben dazu leicht dazu führt, das würde ich Kolio-Imagias auch vorwerfen, dass es sozusagen dann doch nur um die Probleme sozusagen...
Es relativiert, ne?
Genau, es relativiert so ein bisschen, droht zur Metapher zu verkommen, während wir gleichzeitig noch einen sozusagen sehen, wie wir den klassischen Kolonialismus und seine Auswirkungen gerade entlang der Nord-Süd-Macht-Matrix sozusagen weiter erleben, das worüber wir heute gesprochen haben. Deshalb...
Also ihr beide führt gerade eine Diskussion, der mal glaube ich sehr tief drinstecken muss, um die fühlen zu können. Mein erster Eindruck ist, dass es vielleicht sozusagen den Punkt haben könnte, im Sinne von diese Machtstrukturen, die die Mächtigen ausnutzen, werden sich wahrscheinlich, wenn sie die Wahl haben, nicht nur auf die beschränken, die man historisch schon immer ausgenutzt hat, sondern die werden auch alle anderen mitnehmen, die sie ausnutzen können. Aber, apropos Widerstand, was kann man denn besser machen?
Vielleicht um nochmal aufzuzeigen, was spannend ist oder auch innovativ im besten Sinne an der postkolonialen Perspektive, ist eine radikale Entnormalisierung von Ausbeutung, die uns schockieren sollte. Und das ist eine Perspektive, die man auf ganz viel anwenden kann. Und unsere Gesellschaften sind ständig damit beschäftigt zu normalisieren. Wir normalisieren alles Mögliche, was nicht normal sein sollte. Und das ist im Prinzip die umgekehrte Perspektive. Wie sehr wir uns schockieren lassen von den Dingen und entsprechend dann Regulierung fordern, Widerstand leisten. Und in vielen Regionen, von denen wir eben gesprochen haben, beispielsweise gibt es durchaus Gesetzesprojekte, dass Datenschutzgesetze überhaupt erstmal geschrieben und umgesetzt werden. Und ja, das ist denke ich ein Kampf. Der währt schon länger, aber der wird hoffentlich auch nicht erschlafen.
Ganz konkrete Solidarität auch üben. Also da sind wir jetzt gerade eben schon so drüber weggekommen. Aber es gibt beispielsweise in Nairobi gerade sehr interessante Gerichtsverfahren, die Content-ModeratorInnen angestrengt haben gegen Meta. Und die Outsourcing-Firma Sama teilweise auch unterstützt von der britischen NGO Foxcloth Legal. Und auch sozusagen, wo auch aus Deutschland das Superlab beispielsweise mit unterstützt. Also NGOs aus dem globalen Norden, die sozusagen dann sozusagen Solidarität und praktische Solidarität auch üben. Ganz interessantes Gerichtsverfahren. Das läuft übrigens noch. Und ein vorläufiger, das ist auch so ein bisschen, was mir Hoffnung gibt, durchaus an manchen Stellen. Das Gericht in Kenia hat festgestellt, Facebook darf nicht sagen, wir sind ja gar nicht die Arbeitgeber von denen. Die Outsourcing-Firma ist ja der Arbeitgeber. Wir tragen keine Verantwortung. Das heißt, es gibt da auf jeden Fall ja auch Prozesse. Constanze hat es angesprochen, sozusagen die Arbeiter fangen an, sich zu auszutauschen, gewertschaftlich sich zu organisieren, mit einer Stimme zu sprechen. Das sind auf jeden Fall Prozesse, die man unterstützen kann, von denen wir hier unterstützen können, wo wir Solidarität üben.
Mehr noch. Also kann man ja noch generalisieren. Aber wir müssen mal drüber reden. Also das tun wir gerade hier und ich finde, es gibt auch eine Zunahme. Also auch so journalistische Projekte, Podcasts, Radio, Bücher, da gibt es eine Menge, aber wir müssen es halt auch wahrnehmen. Und diese Abstumpfung, von der du sprichst, gegen die muss man sich relativ aktiv werden. In allen anderen Bereichen auch. Würde jetzt nicht nur hier vollzählen, aber ich glaube, da sind wir dran. Und wir sind reich. Verzeihung. Also irgendwann geht ja auch oft um Geld. Man kann irgendwie spenden. Du gibst viele tolle Zwecke, für die man spenden kann. Keine Frage. Und dann muss man für den konkrete politische Forderung draus machen, wie bei allen anderen Bereichen. Na klar, wenn man sich jetzt die verschiedenen Wahlprogramme angeht, bei uns ist ja bald wieder Wahl, kann man schon sehr unterschiedliche Ansätze sehen, etwa was Recycling angeht oder Lieferketten. Da muss man aber auch mal drauf schauen, finde ich. Wir haben eh immer Schwierigkeiten hier in Deutschland, ein anderes Thema im Wahlkampf, weil, naja, ihr wisst schon, zu besprechen. Aber ich finde, man muss es auch zu konkreten politischen Forderungen machen und nicht individualisieren. Wir hatten ja vorhin schon die Lübe.
Und die Lübe auf Unternehmen, die vielleicht gar nicht so bekannt sind.
Oh ja, das ist auch wichtig. Stimmt, ja. Also du hast ja gerade schon irgendwelche genannt, die sind jetzt bekannt wegen einer großen Medien-Story. Ja, aber da gibt es viele mehr.
Jetzt haben wir hier eine reichliche Stunde zusammengesessen und ersten Einblick in dieses Thema gehabt. Und das ist noch längst nicht alles. Deswegen können wir vielleicht da jetzt eine Abschlussrunde machen mit, wo kann man, wenn man jetzt nach der Stunde noch Bock hat, irgendwie noch mehr darüber zu wissen, wo kann man anfangen? Ich vermute ein gewisser Herr Dachwitz würde ein Buch empfehlen, das Digitale Kolonismus heißt, auf demnächst.
Ich hatte mich gerade gemeldet, aber genau um das nicht zu sagen, sondern um deutlich zu machen. Also ich finde es genau, sich zu bilden, Bewusstsein zu schaffen, ist total wichtig. Wir hoffen, dass wir mit unserem Buch einen Teil dazu beitragen können in der deutschen Öffentlichkeit. Aber es ist uns eben auch ganz klar wichtig zu sagen, das ist nichts, was wir erfunden haben. Das ist keine Kritik, die sozusagen die auch nur annähernd sozusagen neu ist, sondern die vor allen Dingen von Forscher in Aktivist in Nicht-Regierungsorganisationen aus dem globalen Süden schon seit langem kommt so und wir hören sie.
Ich verstehe, was du sagen willst. Aber man kann dein Buch sozusagen trotzdem gut lesen, um das sozusagen um einstieg zu finden.
Das stimmt, ich will nur trotzdem einmal, wir sind zwei weiße Autoren aus dem globalen Norden, zwei Männer noch dazu. Das heißt, das ist uns absolut wichtig gewesen im Buch, dass wir diese Stimmen, die ich eben nannte, im Buch auch hören, wiedergeben, so auch, dass sie nicht frei von Machtdynamiken und so. Aber genau, das ist mir wichtig und da gibt es eben viele, es gibt beispielsweise Michael Quedt, südafrikanischer Politikwissenschaftler, der seit langem zu digitalen Kolonialismus veröffentlicht, gibt diverse Studien. Ich kann sie, brauchst du hier wahrscheinlich gar nicht alle aufzuzählen.
Genau, es geht jetzt darum für die interessierten Menschen sozusagen, einen Anknüpfungspunkt zu finden, weil wenn ihr jetzt alle drei Quellen sagt, dann ist schon wieder Optionsparalyse.
Aber der Buch ist in deutscher Sprache, da gibt es nicht so viel, dass das schon...
Ja, stimmt. Ich glaube, Markus versucht so eine Abschlussrunde, weil er versucht... Ja, genau.
Okay, dann schreiben wir noch ein paar Dinge in die Show Notes. Okay. Ansonsten dann empfehle ich noch die Arbeit, aber das mache ich jetzt schon auch noch von Renata Avila, die auch das Nachwort geschrieben hat für unser Buch, in dem sie auch nochmal deutlich macht, dass wir die Systemfrage wirklich stellen müssen sozusagen. Wir brauchen, wir müssen an der Zukunft ganz konkret arbeiten, die sozusagen weggeht von Big-Tech in anderes Wirtschaften sozusagen hin zu kooperativen genossenschaftlichen Modellen, andere Formen der Tech-Regulierung weg von diesem One-Size-fits-all-Ansatz. So, das heißt auch das kann ich nochmal sehr empfehlen, um die großen Systemfragen, die wir ändern müssen, anzugehen.
Okay, Lena, ein Literatur-Tipp von dir.
Gerne. Also meine beiden sind englischsprachig. Das eine wäre ein Podcast, in dem ich Co-host bin, Purple Code. Das sind intersektional feministische Perspektiven auf. Die digitale Transformation und unsere Gäste sind alles Gender-Dissidenzen oder Frauen, die eben einen eigenen Blick haben auf die Tech-Welt. Und darüber hinaus auch ein Blog, der fantastisch ist, der heißt Rest of World, kommt in die Show Notes. Und da gibt es ein Newsletter und man bekommt eine Menge Tech-News und auch über die ganzen politischen Bewegungen drumrum, überall auf der Welt von Regionen, von denen man sonst nicht viel liest.
Also ich würde vielleicht was ganz konkretes empfehlen. Ich hab da heute erst rein gehört, denn Lena hat beim Camp vom CCC im Sommer einen Vortrag gehalten. Ich hab nur in den Anfang gehört, aber ich weiß schon von jemand, der irgendwo hat's auf der Herfahrt gehört.
Ein sehr guter Vortrag.
Genau. Also es ist einfach ein super Einblick. Und wir haben beim Media CCC ja alle Vorträge von den CCC-Veranstaltungen. Wir haben tatsächlich eine ganze Menge, die würde ich auch nochmal zusammenstellen für die Show notes. Also ich finde, das lohnt sich, Leute, die sich damit beschäftigen, anzuhören. Und wir zumindest beim CCC haben eine ganze Menge davon. Und der Camp-Vortrag von Lena wär ein guter Beginn, wenn er einen guter überwächst.
Wie auch immer, in welchem Format ihr euch dem Thema nähern wollt. Podcast, Newsletter, Video, Buch, alles da. Ihr habt also genug zu tun. Ingo, Lena, Konz, vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart.
Danke Markus.
Liebe Hörerinnen, viel Spaß. Obwohl das ein bisschen beklemmend ist, das bei dem Thema zu sagen. Und natürlich wie immer, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Tschüss.